today i'm going to show you an electric
vehicle
that
weighs less than a bicycle
you can carry with you anywhere
that you can charge off a normal wall
outlet in 15 minutes
and you can run it for a thousand
kilometers
on about a dollar of electricity
but when i say the word electric vehicle
people think about vehicles they think
about cars and motorcycles and bicycles
and the vehicles that you use every day
but if you come about it from a
different perspective
you can create some more interesting
more novel concepts
so we built something
i've got some of the pieces in my pocket
here
so this is the motor
this motor has enough power to take you
up the hills of san francisco
at about 20 miles per hour about 30
kilometers an hour
and this battery
this battery right here
has about six miles of range or 10
kilometers
which is enough to cover about half of
the car trips in the u.s alone
but the best part about these components
is that we bought them at a toy store
these are from remote control airplanes
and the performance of these things has
gotten so good that if you think about
vehicles a little bit differently you
can really change things so today we're
going to show you one example of how you
can use this
pay attention to not only how fun this
thing is but also how the portability
that comes with this can totally change
the way you interact with a city like
san francisco
[Music]
[Applause]
so we're going to show you what this
thing can
do it's really maneuverable you have a
handheld remote so you can pretty easily
control acceleration braking
go in reverse if you'd like
also have braking
it's incredible just how light this
thing is i mean this is something you
can pick up and carry with you anywhere
you go
so
i'll leave you with one of the most
compelling facts about this technology
and these kinds of vehicles this uses 20
times less energy
for every mile or kilometer that you
travel than a car
which means not only is this thing fast
to charge and really cheap to build
but it also reduces the footprint of
your energy use in terms of your
transportation so instead of looking at
large amounts of energy needed for each
person in this room to get around in a
city now you can look at much smaller
amounts and more sustainable
transportation
so next time you think about a vehicle i
hope like us you're thinking about
something new
thank you
you